we are now into the second week of war
in europe actually we're in the second
week of watching war in europe from afar
like a person safely looking down from a
high-rise apartment onto a city street
far below you can see the victim being
attacked
you offer to call the police you offer a
word of encouragement for safety you may
even alert others to the injustice you
are observing you will do almost
anything except what the victim actually
needs you to do
which is help
ukraine has asked for help
ukraine begged our senators over the
weekend for help for a no-fly zone for
weapons for more sanctions
anything to stop the massacre
americans have been inspired by the
courage of the ukrainian people by their
resolve their ingenuity their
willingness to fight in the face of
overwhelming odds and americans have
been outraged at the killing of women
and children the images of families
separated from family perhaps forever
in an effort to simply survive we are
outraged at the multiple attempts to
assassinate president zielinski the
recklessness of russia and a near brush
with nuclear disaster yes
america is inspired and outraged just
not enough to climb down from the window
and actually join the fight
we are told there is a contractual
obligation to defend nato countries like
poland and estonia and lithuania
there's a treaty a legal obligation a
contract if you will to defend
contracts are what we signed to repay
bank loans and get cell phone service
morality does not
should not require a contract
most of our obligations in life are not
contractual they're deeper than that
we don't need a contract to defend a
victim from a bully there's no contract
in place when we see a child being
attacked or an elderly person being
assaulted or a single person ambushed by
a larger gang we don't need a contract
to defend a neighbor
we just need to figure out who our
neighbors really are
we're told poland is worth defending so
too with romania and hungary and
slovakia
those are neighbors we're told because
we signed a contract
all that separates those we will defend
from those we will not defend is a
single step
a single step on a map
each of those countries has a border
with ukraine so our moral outrage our
duty to defend is apparently dependent
upon a single step
and a faint boundary line
there's a book on my bedside table
that's been there for many years the
gates of fire it's a 2 000 year old
story about a small group
of greek soldiers who went to fight a
battle that could not win
against an enemy they could not defeat
they left home to lose a battle in hopes
that in the process
they could inspire others to take up
arms and win the war
sparta lost the battle at thermopylae
but their heroism inspired others to go
win the war a war we benefit from 2500
years later
doing the right thing does not require a
treaty doing the right thing does not
depend upon a contract it depends upon
the will of the people
the president is the commander-in-chief
but congress decides when to wage war
and perhaps it's time to debate what
obligation we owe ourselves and others
do we owe the ukrainian people something
more
than what we provided do we owe
ourselves something more than merely
offering good wishes and hopes for safe
passage so innocents can escape their
homeland is that the best the world's
greatest country can offer good thoughts
and a safe escape
route is it time for the people's house
to actually debate what is on the
people's minds which is whether more can
and should be done
for a country being invaded raped and
killed by a bully
there's a marker at the site of the
battle between the spartans and the
persians that marker says
go tell the spartans stranger passing by
that here obedient to their laws we lie
that single sentence served to remind
the world they cared enough to actually
sacrifice
they did not calculate the odds of
winning the battle they calculated the
cost
of losing the larger war
so what will be written about us during
the time a bully ravished a neighboring
country that we relied upon a contract
that we sent good wishes and bought less
russian oil and gas that we seized the
yachts of those who could afford to buy
more yachts that ukraine was not our
neighbor but merely our neighbor's
neighbor
what will be written about this time and
are we okay with that
echoing through the halls of history
joining us now is a former secretary of
dhs and the former top lawyer for the
department of defense mr j johnson mr
secretary thank you for joining us what
is your take on where we currently are
in this war and and putin's real motives
here
well first trey thanks for having me
trey you can appreciate what i'm about
to say because you were a member of
congress and you're a member of the
house intelligence committee
i no longer have access to intelligence
reports i'm no longer a member of the
national security council sitting in the
situation room
wrestling with the choices and the
stakes
so what i say has to be accepted with
that
limitation
trey eight days ago i said publicly
that this thing was going to get a lot
worse that it was going to before it got
better
as americans saw the images of
carnage in the streets in ukraine
innocent men women and children dying as
a result of putin's war crimes
the biden administration was going to
face
domestic and international pressure to
do more than we are doing right now
we're rapidly reaching
the moment of truth when we must decide
as the leader of the free world whether
we have an obligation to become more
directly involved in what is happening
in ukraine
and before we take that step and that
would be a huge step one we have not
seen in generations
we have to remember a couple of things
one
it is much easier to
become involved in an armed conflict
than it is to extricate oneself from one
if we put boots on the ground if we put
americans in harm's way for example in
the air and on the ground
we must have a clear military objective
a clear exit plan
to do so and if we find ourselves in a
conflict in ukraine we will find
ourselves in direct conflict with russia
we managed to avoid conflict with russia
all through the cold war during the
cuban missile crisis 60 years ago in
1962
and so
this is a moment when we need to think
very carefully about next steps
i think that it will be inevitable that
we will have to do more i believe that
putin is detached from reality
i believe he's isolated i believe he's
been president of russia far too long i
believe he's not listening to his
cabinet anymore and he has a detached
sense of reality he probably believed
that we would be that he would be
greeted as a liberator on the streets of
ukraine if he went in which is wrong
and so we need to think carefully about
next steps i think next steps i think
more direct involvement of some kind
will be inevitable
more arms more sanctions
but let's be cautious at this moment
this is a perilous moment trey
mr secretary conflict manifests itself
in different ways including cyber
attacks
is our country prepared
for a cyber attack and by prepared i
mean not just governmental entities but
also the private entities that we rely
upon
trey as you know
most of critical infrastructure
in this country is in private hands
i believe we need to be on high alert
right now
the department of homeland security
through the
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency has put out some very
useful guidance on what those in
critical infrastructure the financial
services agency the defense industrial
base
need to do to protect themselves against
cyber attacks from russia
we've seen cyber attacks from russia
from a russian platform the solar winds
attack for example
and
so we have a huge capability and that
capability right now and my judgment
needs to be on high alert the more we
become involved in this i think the more
it will become inevitable that the
russian government from a russian
platform will direct some form of cyber
attack against the united states
jay johnson former secretary dhs former
top lawyer for our military thank you
for joining us on a sunday night and
loaning us your expertise hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else